hi this is presh talwalkar the season
finale for the simpsons contained a
bunch of cool math examples and i wanted
to discuss them in this video
the culmination of the episode is the
following math problem
in the shape of the m
drawing three straight lines
construct nine
non-overlapping triangles
this is actually a pretty difficult
puzzle
i paused the episode and
actually spent 15 minutes trying to
solve it
i was able to get up to three four five
six pretty easily but then i got to
seven and eight and i couldn't figure
out how to get nine non-overlapping
triangles
so i suggest you try this puzzle and if
you solve it congratulations
you can pause the video or you can just
keep watching i'm going to go through
the rest of the math examples in the
episode
the episode starts off with a very
mathematical joke the springfield math
team has t-shirts that say pi is not
equal to a over b which of course refers
to the fact that pi is irrational
there's also a corny math joke here when
you
solve the expression and read it out
loud you get a very corny joke
the math competition features a bunch of
different questions this question tests
whether you know the order of operations
the correct answer of negative 27 is
shown in the episode
another question tests converting set
notation into interval notation
this can be done without a problem you
just make sure you have the close
brackets on negative three and four
here lisa has to solve an equation of x
squared plus y squared equals 17 plus
two x
and also x minus 1 squared plus y minus
8 squared equals 34.
this could be solved graphically you
could draw out the graph for the
equations and you would have the
intersection of two circles so we're
looking for two points to solve this
system of equations
the quicker way to solve it is to use
algebra
we can rearrange the first expression
moving 2x over the left-hand side and
then expand out the second equation and
now we can see there's a bunch of
cancellations
if we subtract the first equation from
the second equation we'll have x squared
minus 2x and y squared all cancel out
we end up with 16y is equal to 48 which
gives us y is equal to 3.
we can then substitute that back into
our second equation so we'll have x
minus 1 squared
plus
substituting in y equals three in the
second equation we'll end up solving
very easily that the two solutions are
negative two three and four three
here bart sees the problem of x times
the root of x is equal to x
you actually don't need to do much to
solve this equation
very commonly in math competitions the
answers of 0 or 1 are very common they
clearly solve this equation there will
be no other solutions
here we have another question that tests
the order of operations substituting in
x equals seven
we first evaluate the bracket of 3 plus
52
so we have 55 over 4 and then we
subtract
7 plus 1 so we end up with the answer of
5.75
here we have another system of equations
which looks difficult to solve we have a
plus b squared equals 25
and a minus b squared equals 45 so
what's the value of a squared plus b
squared
you might try and solve for a and b and
then you need to square a and square b
but in math competitions there's always
a trick
if you expand out the two equations
we see the only difference is one has
a positive factor of two a b and the
second equation has a negative factor of
two a b
so if we add the two equations together
we end up with two a squared plus two b
squared equals seventy
now we can solve for a squared plus b
squared by dividing the equation in half
so we get the answer of 35.
here we have another system of equations
which looks like you'll have to solve
for x solve for y and then evaluate 3x
plus 5y
once again there's a trick
if you add up the two equations you'll
get 6x plus 10y equals 12.
then divide this in half and you get
three x plus five y equals six
all right now we will return to the
puzzle we need to find to get nine
non-overlapping triangles drawing only
three straight lines
so let's
draw this figure m out so we have more
space to work with
the first line we want to draw will be
skewed coming from the bottom left and
one intersect all the other lines
we'll draw another line
exactly symmetrical starting from the
bottom right
now we have one final line to draw and
we'll draw it horizontally
and now we've created nine
non-overlapping triangles
one two three four
five six seven eight and nine
so it's a pretty cool construction
i hope you figured it out
congratulations if you figured out i did
not come up with this answer
in the episode bart magically comes up
with the answer because he looks at
homer's head of course his hair is in
the shape of the m and he imagines the
solution by constructing it looking at
his at homer's head
so it's a very cool episode
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mindyourdecisions which you can
also follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can also catch me at
preshtalwalkar on a bunch of social
media sites
you can also check out my books on math
and game theory there's a link in the
video description
thanks for watching